.
Acht Tage, 76 km
und knapp 6'000 Höhenmeter -
ein Trekking auf den Kilimandscharo,
das Dach Afrikas.
Drei Frauen und drei Männer
erfüllen sich ihren Lebenstraum.
Seit zwei Tagen sind sie unterwegs.
Den Dschungel
haben sie hinter sich gelassen.
Auf dem Shira-Plateau kämpft Ursula
mit starken Schmerzen in der Brust.
Es drückt mich hier und dort.
Wird sie es auf den Gipfel schaffen?
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Diese Nacht war richtig kalt.
Selbst Bergführer Priskus
ist erstaunt.
Ich habe es auch nicht so erwartet.
Als ich aufwachte, war alles weiss.
Das kommt von der Feuchtigkeit.
Richtiges Eis -
aber ja, das ist Natur.
Das ist nicht vorhersehbar.
Teeservice ans Bett -
wie jeden Morgen.
Thank you.
- Thank you very much.
Im Schlafsack ging es irgendwann,
finde ich. Wie war's bei dir?
Jeder Franken Investition
in den Schlafsack war es wert.- Ja.
Er ist genial, aber es hat
irgendwie Feuchtigkeit reingedrückt,
ein See im Zelt.
Die Handschuhe, die ich hinten
im Zelt hatte, sind komplett nass.
So geht es auch mit dem
Schlafsack und uns allen hier drin.
Irgendwie hat die Feuchtigkeit
dermassen reingedrückt.
Und Ursula? Wie geht es ihr heute?
Das muss auch noch sein
am Kilimandscharo.
Überall, wo es solche hat,
bin ich durchgelaufen.
Das ist immer noch da.
So ein bisschen - nicht konstant,
aber manchmal drückt es einfach.
Ansonsten
fühle ich mich eigentlich gut.
Sie brachten mir noch Aspirin.
Das hat gutgetan.
Die Gruppe übernachtete auf 3'500 m.
Man schläft viel unruhiger,
hatten wir den Eindruck.
Kurt hatte uns schon vorbereitet.
- Ja, dass es so sein wird.
Der Schlaf ist nicht mehr
gleich entspannend.- Nein.
Vielleicht ist es Zufall,
aber wir haben den Eindruck,
wir hätten es heute Nacht
schon gespürt.
Wir sind ...
- ... 100-mal erwacht.
Kaum Schlaf,
plötzlich Halsweh, dann kalte Füsse.
Reiseleiter Kurt
checkt die Befindlichkeiten.
Ursula, guten Morgen.
Wie geht es?
- Gut, glaube ich.
Ist es besser dank der Tabletten?
- Ja.
Gestern gefielst du mir nicht so.
Du siehst lebendiger aus.
Ich sehe lebendiger aus, ja, ja.
- Ja.
Ich bin noch nicht so zuversichtlich
fürs Laufen.
Aber wir laufen jetzt mal.
- (Kurt) Genau.
(Koch) Porridge.
- (Damaris) Is it cinnamon?
Hat jemand von euch
ein Taschenmesser?
Dann bekommt ihr ein Morgenmümpfeli.
Danke vielmals,
das geniessen wir jetzt sehr.
Oh ja, danke dir vielmals.
- Gern geschehen.
Fabian hört man
über den ganzen Zeltplatz.
Wir merken aber, dass wir
in die Höhe kommen.- Wieso?
Er kommt nicht mehr
so ganz tief ins Schnarchen.
(Lachend) Stoppt es in der Mitte?
Er schnarcht so oberflächlich.
- (Fabian) Ist gut jetzt.
(Sandra) Ich habe ihn nicht gehört.
- Auf 4'600 m ist er dann geheilt.
Können wir dann mit ihm ins Zelt?
Heute Morgen
ist mein Bauch mies drauf.
(Damaris) Oh nein.
- Mir ist schlecht. Mal sehen.
(Sandra) Willst du eine Tablette?
- Nein, schon gut.
(Sandra) Ich habe sonst
noch Reisetabletten.
Priskus und seinem Bruder Augustin
ist es wichtig,
dass die Touristen und die Crew
sich kennenlernen.
Das ist euer Dream-Team.
Sie alle geben ihr Bestes,
um sicherzustellen,
dass jede und jeder von euch
ohne Probleme auf den Gipfel kommt.
Einige sind hier, um das Schulgeld
für ihre Kinder bezahlen zu können,
andere,
um ihre Familien zu unterstützen.
Alle haben ihre Gründe,
weshalb sie hier sind.
Wir haben jährlich
zwischen 60'000-70'000 Kunden hier.
Unser Ziel ist es, 150'000 zu haben.
Das ist ein grosses Ziel, aber wir
wünschen uns sehr, es zu erreichen.
Mit Leuten wie euch
werden wir es schaffen.
(Augustin) # Tembea pole pole.
- (Alle) # Hakuna matata!
* Fröhliches Lied:
"Kilimanjaro-Song" -
Adaptation von "Jambo Bwana"
von Them Mushrooms *
(Augustin) # Uhuru.
- (Alle) # Hakuna matata!
(Augustin) # Kilimanjaro.
# Wageni, mwakaribishwa!
# Kilimanjaro - Hakuna matata!
Thaddäus.
- Thaddäus.
* Sie singen auf Suaheli. *
Vom Shira Camp One geht es weiter
über das Shira-Plateau.
Etwa 12 km und 1'000 Höhenmeter
liegen vor ihnen.
Plus ein Zusatzaufstieg
auf die sog. Kathedrale -
für die Akklimatisierung.
Abmarsch.
Daniel steht noch ganz
unter dem Eindruck der Zeremonie.
(Damaris) # Jambo, jambo.
Ich glaube,
die Gegend und das Erlebnis Kili
sind jetzt im absolut
richtigen Moment gekommen.
Ich bin sonst
nicht nahe am Wasser gebaut,
aber ich habe immer wieder
Tränen in den Augen,
wenn ich durch die Steppe gehe
oder heute Morgen
die Zeremonie erleben durfte.
Es kommt gerade so viel von Herzen,
das ist total schön.
Auch bei ihm ist vieles im Wandel,
v.a. beruflich:
Der Familienvater und Verkaufsleiter
aus der Telekombranche
sucht einen neuen Job.
Ich möchte wieder in einen Job,
in dem ich
mit meinen Werten wahrgenommen
werde, meine Werte auch leben kann.
Also dass der Mensch
der Erfolgsgarant ist
und dass man dem Sorge tragen
und Wert geben muss.
Und dass der Mensch
keine Wegwerfware ist.
Das muss ich finden.
Als ehemaliger Mittelstreckenläufer
liebt Daniel Herausforderungen,
aber grössere Gruppen
mag er eigentlich nicht.
Er ist eher der, der schweigt.
Ich höre sehr gerne zu
und nehme auf,
andere machen es umgekehrt.
Das ist total okay,
so ergänzt man sich.
Ursula liegt wieder zurück.
Heute könnte sie
eine Abkürzung nehmen.
Was macht ihr da?
- (Sandra) Steine stapeln.
In der Schweiz
macht man das ja auch.
(Kurt) Ursula,
es geht nachher hier durch.
(Ursula) Dort?
- (Kurt) Ja, abzweigen.
Du hast die Wahl,
entweder mit den Trägern zu gehen,
das wäre
ein bisschen weniger streng,
oder mit uns auf diesen Berg dort.
(Ursula)
Und auf der anderen Seite runter?
(Kurt) Ja.
Dann machst du etwa 3 km mehr.
(Ursula) Ja, ich möchte es machen,
denn heute bin ich fit. - (Kurt) Ja?
Du läufst schön in deinem Tempo.
Wir haben genügend Zeit.
Gehen wir?
- Ursula kommt mit.
(Ursula) Ich gehe schon mal.
- (Kurt) Ja, ja, geh du schon mal.
Wir lassen Ursula
ein bisschen Vorsprung,
damit sie nicht das Gefühl hat,
sie sei eine Last für uns.
Sie ist keine Last.
Wir haben genug Zeit.
Ja.
- Ja.- Hast du kein gutes Gefühl?
Ich weiss nicht, ob sie es
nicht ein wenig überspielt.
Sie sieht nicht so gut aus.
Aber im Kopf stimmt es scheinbar.
Oder sie will es nicht wahrhaben,
dass es ihr nicht so gut geht.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sandra hat erst vor Kurzem
das Reisen entdeckt.
Ihr Mann bleibt lieber zu Hause,
darum reist sie allein -
oft nur mit dem Rucksack.
Das irritiert viele, weil es auf den
ersten Blick gar nicht zu ihr passt.
Ja, manchmal kommst du irgendwohin,
wirst so angeschaut
und du weisst genau, was sie denken.
Ich müsste mich halt verbiegen
und wäre nicht mich selbst,
um in die Norm zu passen
und darauf habe ich keinen Bock.
Ihr Aussehen
war ihr schon immer sehr wichtig.
Lange dachte sie, es sei  d e r
Schlüssel zum Erfolg als Frau.
Das hat ihr ihre Grossmutter
mit auf den Weg gegeben.
Ich hatte eine Phase, als ich
absolut nicht zufrieden mit mir war.
Ich begann dann,
Sachen zu operieren.
Die Nase und andere Dinge
habe ich machen lassen.
Ich dachte,
es gehe mir dadurch besser,
und ich würde mich wohler fühlen.
Ich merke jetzt aber auch:
Es geht beides.
Man kann darauf achten,
wie man aussieht,
und trotzdem in der Natur sein
und Freude daran haben.
Gut auszusehen
hat sie sogar zu ihrem Beruf gemacht.
Die ehemalige Pflegefachfrau
ist seit zehn Jahren selbstständig
in der Beautybranche.
Sie mag es,
an ihre eigenen Grenzen zu gehen.
Mein Vater
war sehr ehrgeizig mit uns Kindern.
Dadurch
wurden wir auch mal gezwungen,
an unsere Grenzen zu gehen,
weil wir mit den Eltern
oft Mountainbiken gingen.
So lernten wir,
dass Ehrgeiz etwas Gutes ist
und man mit Ehrgeiz sehr weit kommt.
Wäre mein Vater
nicht so streng gewesen,
wäre ich heute
wohl nicht an diesem Punkt.
Sie joggt, sie reitet
und ist erfolgreich im Geschäft.
Für Sandra ist auch klar,
dass sie den Gipfel erreicht.
Das will sie sich selbst
und ihrem Vater beweisen.
Ein erster Härtetest ist
die sog. Kathedrale auf 3'872 m Höhe.
(Damaris) Juhu!
(Kurt) Priskus? When I say "Jambo",
then you say ...
(Priskus) # Oh, Jambo, jambo bwana.
* Sie singen
den "Kilimanjaro-Song". *
# Wageni, mwakaribishwa!
# Kilimanjaro - Hakuna matata!
* Jubel *
(Fotograf) Hakuna ...
- (Alle) ... matata!
Keine Fragen.
* Sie lachen. *
Von hier überblickt man
das ganze Shira-Plateau.
Noch sind es knapp 4 Std.
bis zum Camp.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Fabians Grossvater
war ein bekannter Bergführer,
doch er hat seine Begeisterung
für die Berge
erst im Militärdienst entdeckt.
Ich habe mich irgendwie
ins Gebirge verliebt.
Das lebensfeindliche Umfeld,
in das man nicht hingehört,
hat einen gewissen Reiz für mich.
Wenn du dich hier umsiehst:
Ohne die Porters
und die Unterstützung
würde das wohl
keiner von uns schaffen.
Das Militär hat noch etwas anderes
ins Rollen gebracht:
Er hat intensiv begonnen,
Krafttraining zu machen.
Ich wollte v.a. abnehmen.
Ich war immer ein bisschen pummelig,
nicht schlimm,
aber ich hatte immer etwas dran.
Dann habe ich begonnen,
zu trainieren.
Man macht dann halt immer weiter.
Man könnte sagen,
dass es eine Sucht ist,
aber auch ein Hobby.
Nach der Arbeit
gehe ich ins Fitness.
Andere gehen heim und schauen fern.
Es hat mir auch sehr geholfen
fürs Selbstbewusstsein.
Früher hatte ich recht Mühe damit,
mich in meinem Körper wohlzufühlen.
Fabian arbeitet seit der Lehre als
Servicemonteur bei der gleichen Firma
und lebt schon länger
in einer Beziehung.
Im Moment ist er ein bisschen ratlos,
was er mit seinem Leben
anfangen soll.
Ich habe noch kein Ziel.
Das endet auch ein bisschen
in einer Antriebslosigkeit,
denn ich arbeite auf nichts hin.
Ich gehe einfach arbeiten
und verdiene mein Geld.
Dieser Job
bereitet mir wirklich auch Freude,
aber ich würde mich im Leben
schon gerne noch steigern
und auf etwas hinarbeiten können.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
was für mich das Richtige ist.
Ich hoffe,
mir wird hier einiges klar.
Die Träger sind bereits im Camp
und müssen Wasser holen -
zum Kochen, zum Waschen,
für 60 Leute.
Doch Wasser wird langsam Mangelware.
Früher fanden wir
5 Min. entfernt vom Camp Wasser.
Heute müssen wir 25 Min. laufen.
Die Gletscher sind
in den letzten Jahren geschmolzen
und das Eis ist bald weg.
Das ist eine grosse Herausforderung.
Wenn es oben kein Eis mehr gibt,
haben wir unten auch kein Wasser.
Wir machen uns grosse Sorgen.
Die nächste Regenzeit
kommt erst in zwei Monaten,
und ich bin nicht sicher,
ob das Wasser noch so lange reicht.
Wenn es nicht reicht,
wissen wir nicht, was passiert.
Die Einheimischen
trinken das Wasser so,
für die Touristen wird es entkeimt.
(Damaris)
Wir haben auf dich gewartet.
(Klaus) Hey, auguri, gratuliere.
(Fabian) Dann ist das also
das richtige Camp?- (Damaris) Ja.
(Klaus) Hakuna matata!
(Fabian) Mega Bizeps.
* Damaris lacht. *
Ursula kommt nicht vom Fleck.
Ich möchte Klaus gerne fragen,
wie das mit der Lunge ist.
Denn die schmerzt ja nicht einfach
aus dem Nichts.
Das hat ja einen Grund,
dass die jetzt schmerzt.
Das sagt mir ja etwas,
aber ich weiss nicht, was.
Sie ist nicht die Einzige,
die kämpft:
Auch Priskus' Schwester Brigit
ist am Anschlag.
Ich habe nichts zu sagen heute,
ich bin so fertig.
(Damaris) Ursi!
(Klaus) Hey, auguri, megagut.
* Ursula kichert. *
Super, super, super.
Man spürt es langsam.
- Es atmet.
Ja, die Pumpe arbeitet.
Aber es ist schön.
- Megaschön.
Unglaublich, und die Belohnung
dort oben ist unglaublich.
Nun sitzen wir wirklich davor.
- Ja.
Mal sehen,
wo sie uns heute einquartieren.
Und Daniels Schlafsack?
Ich glaube, der ist gleich trocken.
Ich wollte eben schauen.
Er war schon im Zelt
und die Tasche ist relativ warm.
Und ja, der wird noch nie so gut
gerochen haben wie jetzt dann.
Der lüftet jetzt gut aus.
(Sandra) Morgen wird es streng sein,
mit diesem Rauf und Runter.
Sie haben heute gesagt,
es sei nicht streng,
aber ich bin jetzt schon
an meine Grenzen gestossen.
Es ist nicht,
dass du nicht mehr kannst,
bei dir ist es die Luft,
dass du nicht atmen kannst.
Nicht, dass du nicht mehr kannst,
denn du kannst.
Ja, ich muss immer so strecken.
Ohne Rucksack bringt auch nichts?
- Doch, viel.
Du könntest ihn morgen
vielleicht von Anfang an abgeben.
Das Essen ist vielseitig,
doch alle haben ihre Essgewohnheiten:
Damaris isst vegan
und Fabian hält sich sonst strikt
an einen Ernährungsplan.
(Kurt) Wenn die Suppe nicht stört.
Wenn ich sehe, was sie z.T. essen -
gut, man sieht sie kaum essen,
sie essen wohl nicht viel -,
dann kann ich mich nicht beklagen.
Es ist keine Riesenumstellung,
da es hier sehr gemüsebasiert ist.
Und ... ähm ...
Es schmeckt mir sehr.
Daher komme ich hier
voll auf meine Kosten.
Ich vermisse nichts.
Für mich ist es relativ schwierig,
zu essen.
Wenn meine Mutter das sieht,
ist sie stolz, dass ich Gemüse esse,
denn es bleibt mir
nichts anderes übrig.
Im Moment befinde ich mich
in einem Zustand ...
Die Omelette wollte ich
eigentlich noch essen ...
In meinem jetzigen Zustand
mag ich nichts.
Das Nachtessen lasse ich auch aus.
Nicht schon wieder essen.
Es ist meist in der Menge zu viel.
Ein kleines Trostpflaster ist,
zu wissen,
was wir nicht essen,
das essen dann sie.
Das ist aber auch wieder komisch
im Sinne von:
Sie nehmen das,
was wir nicht mehr nehmen.
Da ist man so: "Na ja ..."
Eigentlich sind wir
alle zusammen hier am Berg.
Sie tragen ja schon genug
mit Zelten, Toiletten,
dem ganzen Essen, dem Wasser ...
So viel - und sie sind z.T.
nicht mehr die Jüngsten.
Das ist Schwerstarbeit.
Die Leute, die diesen Berg rocken,
das sind diese Träger und Helfer,
finde ich,
denn es ist extrem, was sie leisten.
Sie haben gesagt,
sie seien extrem froh um den Job.
Aber das Traurige ist,
sie haben kein einziges Mal gesagt,
dass sie ihn gern machen
oder weil sie ihn wollen,
sondern nur aus traurigen Gründen.
Man hat weniger schlechtes Gewissen,
weil sie froh um den Job sind,
aber sie wollen ihn nicht,
sie brauchen ihn.
Für die Guides und Träger gibt es
Ugali, den Maisbrei - wie immer.
Ursula hat sich zurückgezogen
und will von Klaus und Kurt wissen,
was mit ihrer Lunge sein könnte
und wie es weitergehen soll -
aber nicht vor der Kamera.
Weiter mitkommen kann sie nur,
wenn sie gesund ist.
Sonst können wir sie
nicht mitnehmen, unmöglich.
Es wird strenger.
Wir haben dann noch eine Felswand.
Das ist körperlich streng
und wir haben gesehen,
dass es gestern
schon nicht so gut ging.
Drei bis vier Tage kann sie so
nicht durchhalten am Berg,
das ist zu streng.
Nach langer Diskussion
beschliessen Kurt und Klaus,
dass Ursula
nicht weiter aufsteigen darf.
Sie vermuten ein Herzproblem.
Aber erst einmal
wollen sie sie schlafen lassen.
Am nächsten Morgen:
direkte Sicht auf den Mount Meru.
Brigit muss jeweils früher los,
damit sie die Etappe schafft.
Ich schlief nicht gut,
aber heute geht es besser.
Gestern war ein harter Tag.
Mittlerweile
haben alle Probleme in der Nacht.
Ich schlief nicht so gut.
Irgendwie war ich unruhig.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass der Körper
arbeitet, sich angleicht, anpasst.
Jetzt, gegen Morgen,
habe ich aber tief geschlafen.
Die Träger schlafen dicht gedrängt
im Koch- und Esszelt,
um sich zu wärmen.
Die wenigsten
haben gute Schlafsäcke dabei.
(Fabian) Ganz okay. Heute Morgen
ist mir etwas schwindlig.
Okay.
- Aber es wird hoffentlich besser.
Trink mal etwas, einen Kaffee,
und dann sehen wir weiter.
Ich bin völlig ausgetrocknet:
trockene Lippen usw.
Sie haben einen anstrengenden Tag
vor sich.
Erstmals geht es auf 4'600 m.
Kurt hat die schwierige Aufgabe
übernommen, mit Ursula zu reden.
Ich dachte gestern darüber nach,
was du erzählt hattest.
(Ursula) Was habe ich erzählt?
- Du sagtest, du hättest Angst.
Ja, genau, ich war an einen Punkt
gekommen, an dem ich dachte ...
Klaus sagte ein paar Sachen,
was das hier sein könnte.
Jawohl.
Dann stellt sich irgendwo die Frage:
Ist das riskant, was ich tue?
Der Körper redet ja.
- Genau.
Wenn du es immer ignorierst
und nicht hinhörst, was er sagt ...
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
jetzt runterzugehen? - Nein, morgen.
Ihr geht heute so und so,
und du hast gesagt, ich kann so.
Könntest du schon,
aber du hast seit zwei Tagen
hier Schmerzen.
Drei.
- Drei.
Weisst du,
ich rede aus eigener Erfahrung.
Ich hatte mal
ziemlich ähnliche Symptome ...
... und es endete
in einer Herzoperation.
Du hast jetzt drei Tage
Probleme gehabt.
Es tat mir sogar in der Nacht weh,
ohne Anstrengung.
Und du willst dennoch raufgehen?
- Ursula, guten Morgen.
Tschau, Klaus.
Als ich in eurem Gespräch
gehört habe,
dass es auch heute Nacht
Symptome machte,
da gingen bei mir
alle Alarmglocken los.
Aha.
- Nein, wirklich.
Das muss man sehr ernst nehmen.
So ernst
wollte ich es auch nicht nehmen.
Also bis zum Beweis vom Gegenteil
glaube ich,
dass deine Herzkranzgefässe
verkalkt sind in einer Art,
in der es jetzt relevant wird.
Wir sind auf fast 4'000 m.
Dich jetzt noch körperlich belasten,
wenn du es auch in der Nacht
beim Schlafen gespürt hast,
das wäre ...
Aber rüberlaufen darf ich?
... eigentlich nicht verantwortbar.
Jetzt mal runter,
aus der dünnen Luft raus - Punkt 1.
Punkt 2: in ein Spital.
Ich bin doch nie krank.
Wenn du jetzt vernünftig bist,
hast du eine Chance,
dass du in ein paar Jahren
wieder hier hochkommen kannst.
Wenn etwas passiert,
dann passiert etwas.
Dann ist nicht nur
eine Zehe gebrochen.
Ich weiss schon, der Körper redet ja
und nicht vergebens.
Dass ich nicht auf den Gipfel kann,
ist mir egal.
Damit habe ich mich
bereits gestern abgefunden.
Aber ins Spital will ich nicht.
Ich will nicht ins Spital.
Obwohl es für Ursula schwierig ist:
Im Camp organisiert man über Funk
einen Rettungswagen.
Als sie gestern sagte,
sie hätte Angst,
kam mir meine eigene Geschichte
in den Sinn.
Dann realisierte ich, was sie hat.
Sie hat das mitgenommen von zu Hause
und sich das nicht am Berg geholt.
Für sie ist es nun schwierig,
das zu akzeptieren.
Darum brauchte es Überredungskünste,
damit sie einwilligt, runterzugehen.
Wir gehen alle für dich
und du schaust bitte zu dir.
Ja, ich schau zu mir.
Tragt Sorge auf dem Berg.
Ursula und ich gehen jetzt runter
ins Spital, um zu schauen, was ist.
Ich hoffe, wir treffen euch am Gate,
wenn ihr runterkommt, wieder.
Ihr könnt das allein machen,
ihr habt gute Führer bei euch
und ihr könnt ihnen vertrauen.
Dani.
- (Daniel) Trage Sorge zur dir.
Hey, Fabian.
Du bist ein guter Typ,
es hat mich gefreut.
Ich hoffe sehr,
dass wir uns unten sehen.
Ihr seid so fit, ihr schafft das.
Ihr hört von mir.
(Sandra) Unbedingt. Trage Sorge.
Mich nimmt es schon gerade mit,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Jetzt gehen wir für Ursi hoch.
- Das machen wir.
Ursula und Kurt
steigen ab bis zum Rettungswagen.
Die anderen fünf müssen heute
700 Höhenmeter überwinden -
zum sog. Lava Tower auf 4'600 m.
Dann geht es wieder 700 Höhenmeter
hinunter ins Baranco Camp.
Ein weiterer Akklimatisierungstag.
Kurz vor 9 Uhr geht's los.
4'000 m überschritten.
- 4'000 m!- Juhu!
Das erste Mal auf 4'000 m.
- Hey, nur noch 1'800 m.
Wir feiern die 4'000 m,
die wir schon haben.
Positiv denken: Es ist nicht mehr
so weit wie auch schon.- Ja.
Nur noch 1'800 m.
Das ist nur noch der Pilatus.
* Dynamische Musik *
Nach 2 Std. Marsch - Pause.
Die Höhe? 4'300 m haben wir
jetzt gerade überschritten.
Juhu!
- Wart ihr schon mal so hoch?
Nein.
- Noch nie.
Ab jetzt ist jeder Schritt Neuland.
- Ja.
Etwas verloren fühlen sie sich
schon ohne Ursula und Kurt.
(Fabian) Schade.
- Ja.- (Klaus) Sie fehlt schon.
(Fabian) Vater Kurt natürlich auch.
- Unser Kilimandscharo-Daddy.
(Fabian) Er war für jede Situation
der Ansprechpartner.
Er kann mit seiner Erfahrung
all das Blöde,
das im Kopf herumschwirrt,
relativieren
und als total Nebensächliches abtun.
Dann denkst du wieder:
"Ah, okay, das passt."
(Fabian) Die Sorgen ausreden.
- Genau.
Dennoch
fühlt man sich ernst genommen.
Ich hatte nicht den Eindruck,
dass er blöd von uns dachte.
Nein, im Gegenteil.
Er hat uns ernst genommen
und gesagt, es sei alles gut.
Trotzdem ist er auch ehrlich
und sagt: "Da müsst ihr aufpassen."
* Dynamische Musik *
Dort hinten ist gut.
Ich gehe auf die Frauenseite.
- Dort sind wir nicht die Einzigen.
Dort ist die Männerseite.
- Pinkelpause.
Der sieht grandios aus.
Ein grosses Problem am Berg
sind die Fäkalien.
Die Gruppe nimmt ihr WC-Papier mit,
ist damit aber die Ausnahme.
Überall hinter den Felsen
liegt Papier herum und es stinkt.
Das Problem ist,
dass viele Leute denken,
das Toilettenpapier
löse sich bei Regen auf.
Aber das ist eine alpine Wüste,
hier regnet es nicht viel.
Ich hoffe,
die Parkverwaltung beginnt bald,
die Touristen zu erziehen,
sodass sie, wenn sie Pipi machen,
das Papier wieder einpacken
und im Camp
in den Abfallsäcken entsorgen.
Auf 4'400 m kreuzt die Lemosho-Route
die Machame-Route.
Die Machame-Route ist die kürzere,
die viele Touristen wählen.
Plötzlich wimmelt es von Menschen.
Wir sind auf dem Weg zum Lava Tower.
Dort werden wir Mittag essen.
Lava Tower ist auf 4'600 m,
dann geht's wieder runter
ins Baranco Camp.
Es geht allen gut ausser Ursula,
sie ist schon runtergegangen.
Die anderen machen es super.
Wunderbar. Es ist herrlich,
etwas viele Leute, viel Traffic,
aber wir sind schön
an denen vorbeigezogen.
Es ist gut gegangen.
Ein bisschen durstig vom Wind
wahrscheinlich, aber super.
(Fabian) Wenn ich hinaufschaue,
ist es irgendwie motivierend
und gleichzeitig Furcht einflössend.
Jetzt sind wir das erste Mal
ganz unten, am Anfang des Felsens.
Geil oder, kommt gut.
- Ja.
Die hilft auf den Lava Tower:
Glücksmango.
Wie geht es mit der Höhe?
Hier ist sie.
Hier vorne spüre ich sie.
Aber sonst gut.
Der Bauch rumpelt, seit ich
auf Hallenbadwasser umgestellt habe.
Ich muss es wohl mal auswechseln.
Sie haben es extrem gut gemeint
mit Desinfizieren.
* Dynamische Musik *
Nach 4 Std. Aufstieg:
endlich der Lava Tower.
(Damaris) Da kommen sie schon.
- (Sandra) Go, Jungs! Bravo!
Photo time!
Wie hoch sind wir hier?
- Super!
(Flüsternd) Wow!
- Wow!
Wow, du kannst stolz sein.
4'600 m. Halleluja!
- 4'600 m!
So hoch war ich noch nie.
- Ich auch nicht.
(Sandra) Eine Premiere für alle.
Am Schluss
war ich erstmals gefordert.
Nicht vom Atem her, überhaupt nicht,
sondern von der Energie her.
Auf dem Lava Tower
gibt es erstmals wieder Handyempfang.
Priskus telefoniert mit Kurt.
Dieser ist mit Ursula
im Spital angekommen.
Die Untersuchung
steht jedoch noch aus.
Alright.
Die Gletscher sind nun richtig nah -
jedenfalls das,
was von ihnen übrig geblieben ist.
Als ich zum ersten Mal auf
dem Gipfel des Kilimandscharos war,
war der Gletscher
etwa 10 m vom Weg entfernt.
Heute ist er mehr als 40 m weg.
Wir machen uns schon Sorgen.
In fünf oder zehn Jahren
wird es vielleicht
keinen Gletscher mehr geben.
* Beschwingte Musik:
"Africa" von Kosinus *
# Jambo, jambo bwana.
(Sandra)
# Kilimanjaro - Hakuna matata!
* Beschwingte Musik:
"Africa" von Kosinus *
(Sandra) Juhu! Wir können überholen.
* Beschwingte Musik:
"Africa" von Kosinus *
Das Baranco Camp auf 3'900 m.
Es ist 16.30 Uhr.
Machen wir dort ein Foto?
- Ladys, wie geht's?
Super.
- Gut.
Eine rote Tomate, etwas verbrannt,
aber sonst gut.
Ein bisschen schwer,
jetzt, nach 700 m Abstieg,
habe ich den Eindruck, mit jedem
Schritt fliesse das Blut runter.
Aber noch okay.
- Hey, Jungs.
Gut gemacht.
Jetzt sind die noch dran,
nachher schleichen wir uns rein.
(Klaus) Genau, drängen wir uns rein.
Okay, kommt! Die Schweizer!
(Fotograf) Chapati!
- (Alle) Chapati!
Was sagte sie? Risi!
(Alle) Risi!
- Was das auch immer heisst.
(Klaus) Thank you.
Zu hören, dass sie noch mehr Leute
diesen Berg raufjagen wollen,
bricht mir ein bisschen mein Herz,
denn das macht als Wanderer
wohl keinen Spass mehr,
wenn doppelt so viele hier wären.
Wir sind uns in den Schweizer Bergen
halt einsame Wege gewohnt.
Wir sind auch Teil des Gewusels,
wir gehören auch dazu.
Wirklich?
- Ja, gleich wie jeder andere.
Wir tragen unseren Teil auch
dazu bei, dass es am Berg wimmelt.
Wir sind ja Botschafter.
- (Ironisch) Ja.
Suchen wir mal unser Hotel,
unser Zuhause.
(Klaus) Ich habe für heute Nacht
ein Penthouse gemietet.
(Damaris) Ach ja?
70'000 Touristen
besteigen den Berg jedes Jahr.
Heute sind etwa 700 Leute hier.
Im Kochzelt laufen die Vorbereitungen
bereits auf Hochtouren.
Es gibt Gurkensuppe und - Sandra hat
Glück - ausnahmsweise mal Fleisch.
Der Berg rückt näher,
die Route wird strenger.
Sandra hat sich nicht nur verbrannt,
sie hat auch eine beidseitige
Augenentzündung eingefangen.
(Damaris) Atmen, Sandra.
- (Klaus) Es ist rot.
Es tut weh.
Ah, verdammt.
Sind meine Wimpern noch dran?
- (Beide) Ja.
Ich hatte vor zwei, drei Tagen
Sand drin.
Dann haben wir es schon ausgespült.
Seither hat es immer
ein bisschen gebrannt
und jetzt ist es
ganz schlimm geworden.
Jetzt laufen Tränen, rot und jetzt
ist auch noch die ganze Höhle zu,
aber Fieber habe ich nicht.
Wir halten uns an jedem Strohhalm.
- Das ist die Hauptsache.
Ich dachte oben: "Komisch,
ich habe ein aufgedunsenes Gesicht."
Ich sagte zu ihr:
"Schau, wie das geschwollen ist."
Ich dachte aber,
es sei etwas anderes.
Wenn ich es mir hier unten überlege,
ist klar:
Wenn der Körper einen Infekt hat,
dann macht es manchmal auch so.
Klaus hat alle Hände voll zu tun.
Ich doktere hier nicht rum.
Ich versuche einfach, die Probleme
zu lösen, die auftauchen,
und auf dieser Schiene
Support zu bieten, Punkt.
Am liebsten hätte ich nichts zu tun.
Es sollte ihnen allen gut gehen,
aber ja.
Auch Daniel hat ein Problem.
(Klaus) Dann wären wir wieder
beim Antibiotikum.
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
- Okay.
(Damaris) Oder wir nehmen mal ...
Ja, es hat sich verschlimmert
und mir ist nicht mehr so wohl.
Auch ein bisschen Durchfall,
etwas wässrig.
Das zehrt an den Kräften.
Genau die habe ich dabei, die nehme
ich seit zwei Tagen.- Sehr gut.
Super, danke vielmals.
Soll ich das jetzt nehmen?- Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Nach dem Essen
gibt es den Gesundheitscheck.
Priskus misst jeden Tag
Sauerstoffsättigung und Puls.
Okay.
- Dockingstation.
F a s t  alle sind noch da.
Priskus und Klaus versuchen nochmals,
Kurt zu erreichen wegen Ursula.
Hallo, Priskus.
- Hello, Kurt. Good evening.
- Hoi, guten Abend.
- Hoi, Klaus. Hoi.
Du, wir holten eben
die Werte im Spital.
Hörst du mich?
- Ja, ich höre zu.
Ah, gut. Also, die Blutwerte
sind gut, alle im richtigen Range.
Aber das EKG zeigt bei einem Gefäss
eine Verengung.
Okay.
Kann man das am EKG sagen,
wie gross sie ist?
Nein, das siehst du im EKG nicht.
Haben sie euch
eine Diagnose gegeben?
Ich weiss nicht, welche Arterie,
aber eine ist etwas verschlossen.
Also jetzt wichtig:
keine grossen
körperlichen Anstrengungen ...
... keine Wanderungen,
keine Märsche usw.
Aber morgen können wir schon
wandern gehen, oder?
Nein, nein, nein, nein -
ein glasklares Nein.
Soll sie im Hotel bleiben?
Jetzt nicht körperlich anstrengen,
auch wenn sie sich super fühlt.
Mit körperlicher Anstrengung
kann es jederzeit wiederkommen.
Ja.
Der Worst Case ist, wenn sich
das Gefäss ganz verschliesst.
Ja.
Nichts tun,
das das provozieren kann,
d.h.,
jetzt in den Relax-Modus übergehen.
Ja.
Okay, ja, merci, gut.
Gute Nacht.
Danke, tschüss.
- Danke, tschüss.
Okay.
Nicht klar, was passiert wäre,
wenn kein Arzt dabei gewesen wäre.
Zum Glück liessen wir sie nicht
hier hinauflaufen.
Das hätte ziemlich schlimm
rauskommen können.
Das war doch heavy mit dieser Höhe -
4'600 m und dann wieder hier runter.
Ja.
Danke für die Hilfe
und die Abklärungen.
Super gemacht
mit dieser Untersuchung.
Das hätte man
nicht besser machen können.
(Sandra) Hey, danke vielmals.
Ursula ist in Sicherheit, aber wie
geht es mit den anderen weiter?
Sie kämpfen mit
verschiedenen Gesundheitsproblemen.
Noch liegen drei Tage vor ihnen
bis zum Gipfel -
und es werden die strengsten sein.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023